Jimmy asks what's your favorite city in
the world to drink wine in Jimmy my
favorite city in the world drink wine is
in is the city that has my friends and
family in at that moment that I'm
sharing that wine with there is no like
you know atmosphere that dictates my
happiness of drinking wine there's no
pretty French Riviera or the gorgeous
mountains I don't give a crap about that
stuff what I care is who am i drinking
it with so I could be in Newark big ups
to newark not dissing if it's with
somebody I love and we're enjoying wine
then that's what is the driving force
and so then it would be Newark the hotel
lobby in austin in south by 2007 is one
of my favorite times of all time of
having wine the parking lot of a jets
game you know it you know inside the
caves of wineries in tuscany like it's
happened in a lot of places but it's
never been the setting i don't care
about that stuff it's been the people
i'm sharing it with don't forget to
subscribe to my youtube channel
jab